bonjour à tous ma première question est
bien évidemment à l'intention du
président ukrainien chers collègue je
parlerai donc
ukrainien monsieur le Président cher
volo Dimir nous avons vu les résultats
de votre visite au Royaume-Uni puisque
le Premier ministre britannique a
annoncé que des pilotes Ukrainiens
pourraient être formés au Royaume-Uni si
bien que d'ici au moment où l'Ukraine
obtiendra les avions de combat les
pilotes Ukrainiens auront été formés
comme il se doit et lorsque vous avez
rencontré
le chancelier allemand et le président
français à Paris il n'y a pas eu de
promesses concrète est-ce que cela
signifie que elles n'ont pas été
annoncées publiquesment ou est-ce que
cela signifie qu'elles n'ont tout
simplement pas été faites est-ce que
vous pourriez nous en dire plus vous
venez de rencontrer par ailleurs les 27
dirigeants de l'Union européenne vous
avez rencontré des représentants des
institutions européennes nous avons bien
compris que votre priorité était de
trouver une solution
permettant que l'Ukraine obtienne des
missiles de longue portée et des avions
de chasse est-ce que vous vous êtes
approchés de cet objectif à la suite de
ces échanges voilà mes questions à
l'intention du président
ukrainien maintenant j'aimerais
peut-être aussi poser une question au
président
des deux institutions vous avez évoqué
la question de l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à
l'Union européenne pour autant que nous
sachions
nous avions sept critères et la première
évaluation sera publiée vers la fin 2023
et ensuite le Conseil devra décider
d'ouvrir au nom les négociations
d'adhésion encore une fois avant la fin
2023 quel est votre évaluation de la
probabilité de l'ouverture de ces
négociations encore en 2023 et est-il
possible que au-delà de ces 7 conditions
on en impose d'autres à l'Ukraine
[Musique]
je vais essayer de répondre
c'était de longues questions je vais moi
aussi répondre en
ukrainien
lors de notre visite à Londres nous
avons engrangé des résultats nous nous
sommes approchés d'une solution sur la
formation de nos pilotes et de les
missiles l'ont portés c'est évidemment
un moment important puisque nous voulons
obtenir ces avions dont nous avons
besoin par ailleurs il y a des accords
qui effectivement sont positifs mais
pour autant ne sont pas publics
lorsque ces accords pourront se
concrétiser alors nous nous le saurons
simplement la Russie ne cesse de nos
menacées de nouvelles agressions et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous nous
en tenons là pour ce qui est de ma
visite à Paris j'y ai rencontré le
président Macron et le chancelier
Scholtz et nous avons eu une réunion
très importante
intense dirais-je
pour moi c'était un échange positif
et vous me posez la question de décision
concrète et il n'y a pas grand chose que
je souhaite annoncer publiquement la
seule chose que je puis dire c'est que
nous travaillons ensemble au
renforcement de nos capacités nous
parlons de capacité offensive nous
parlons d'équipements nous parlons de
chars et j'ai entendu
j'ai retenu un message positif de ces
échanges pour ce qui est maintenant de
la réunion avec les 27 chefs d'État et
de gouvernement de l'Union il faut bien
comprendre que
nous avons donc les dirigeants des 27
est un membre de l'Union qui représente
chacun leur société et je dois leur
adresser notre plus grande gratitude la
première chose pense que je dois dire
ici c'est à quel point nous disons merci
des chiffres que vous entendez de toutes
les mesures concrètes qui ont été
annoncées aujourd'hui merci du soutien
de la société civile merci du soutien
qui est apporté à nos citoyens qui ont
dû se déplacer merci du soutien porté à
notre économie qui vient renforcer la
résilience de notre pays si nous avons
une économie résiliente notre armée
résiliente une armée résiliente celle du
chemin vers la victoire merci donc
infiniment de ce soutien maintenant vous
me posez la question du résultat de ces
échanges et bien
nous nous sommes effectivement réunis
mais j'ai encore un certain nombre de
réunions bilatérales qui m'attendent et
donc le travail est encore en cours
que ces conseils européens c'est
vraiment l'occasion pour un certain
nombre de dirigeants européens de dire
qu'ils sont disposés à fournir un
soutien militaire supplémentaire et nous
sommes convaincus de l'urgence qu'il y a
à le faire sur le processus
d'élargissement je suis confiant parce
que nous avons vu ces dernières semaines
ces derniers mois à quel point l'Ukraine
a rapidement été en mesure de démontrer
sa capacité à mettre en oeuvre des
réformes extrêmement importantes et à
engranger des progrès en la matière nous
le savons dans les semaines à venir
l'Ukraine continuera à mettre en oeuvre
ses réformes ensuite la Commission
pourra faire un rapport et puis ensuite
le Conseil d'ici à la fin de l'année
devra décider des étapes à suivre
la commission effectivement travaille
maintenant la main avec le gouvernement
ukrainien sur
le progrès à réaliser puisque nous avons
vous le savez cette étape à franchir
cette critères pas plus pour répondre à
votre question puisque ce sont les sept
sur lesquelles nous nous sommes mis
d'accord et il est vraiment
impressionnant de constater que la
partie
ukrainienne s'est comporté de façon
éminemment professionnelle pour mettre
en oeuvre avec une grande compétence
toutes les réformes nécessaires y
compris la stratégie de lutte contre la
corruption la nouvelle loi sur les
médias autant d'étapes essentielles dans
le cadre de ce processus il reste encore
à faire mais ce qui est important de
comprendre c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
calendrier rigide c'est un processus qui
est fondé sur le mérite et c'est donc au
pays de candidats de déterminer jusqu'au
il souhaite aller à quelle cadence il
souhaite procéder après nous avons
publié un rapport au printemps mais
vraiment l'objectif est de pouvoir
faire le bilan de tous les progrès
engrangé dans le rapport sur
l'élargissement qui lui est publié à
l'automne voilà c'est l'objectif que
nous partageons il est évident que la
Commission offre tout le soutien
possible à l'Ukraine que nous
conseillons l'Ukraine autant que faire
se peut il est très important maintenant
et très utile que nous ayons le
secrétariat qui est établi à Bruxelles
et à Kiev dès le départ en effet il
était extrêmement clair que dès lors que
nous allions avancer et aujourd'hui nous
travaillons notamment sur les
réparations et la relance rapide et on
se par la suite il faudra plancher à la
reconstruction que tout ceci devait
s'accompagner de réforme qui allait donc
jeter les fondements de la voie vers
l'adhésion
je vous en prie
bonjour chers collègues et je vais aussi
parler
ukrainien
je voudrais vous poser une question
sur les forces armées ukrainiennes
nous savons
[Musique]
que
nos forces armées se sont des
volontaires et nous travaillons en
coopération étroite avec le Conseil
européen avec l'Union européenne certes
mais
malheureusement
au sein de l'Union européenne certains
ne
ressentent pas dans leur chair que le
pays était en guerre
et
les gens se divertissent et oublient que
à baroute et ailleurs les gens vivent
dans un enfer
qu'en pensez-vous que l'ensemble du pays
l'ensemble des sociétés
comprendront que le pays est en guerre
et feront cause commune avec les forces
armées ukrainiennes
merci beaucoup pour cette question
essayez de ne pas tout mélanger
il est très difficile de faire une
guerre pendant si longtemps et nous
sommes très reconnaissants vis-à-vis de
nos forces armées très reconnaissants
pour ceux qui sont sur la ligne de front
c'est eux qui font le sacrifice de leur
vie mais il y a également
d'autres personnes qui font la guerre
qui ne sont pas sur la ligne de front
qui travaillent qui paie des impôts et
se faisant il
soutiennent notre armée nous sommes des
êtres humains il y a des personnes aussi
en Ukraine qui sont fatigués c'est une
question
psychologique il y a des personnes qui
ont déjà besoin de soutien psychologique
il y a des gens qui ont perdu des
proches des parents il y a ceux qui
souhaiteraient oublier leur chagrin ce
sont des êtres humains nous sommes tous
des êtres humains nous sommes tous
différents et nous devons en tenir
compte nous ne pouvons pas traiter tout
le monde de la même façon nous ne
pouvons pas dire que tout le monde doit
absolument faire telle ou telle chose
soyons soyons en conscients et là je
suis d'accord avec vous tout un chacun
doit comprendre que malheureusement la
guerre se poursuit malheureusement
et que ce qui est important c'est notre
unité c'est notre unité qui donnera la
résilience nécessaire à nos soldats
c'est vrai certaines personnes en
Ukraine souhaitent partir en vacances
souhaite se reposer
mais il ne s'agit pas de millions de
personnes qui ne veulent pas
soutenir l'effort des forces armées et
d'ailleurs ça n'est pas simplement dans
notre pays dans toutes les guerres il y
a eu des situations comme celle-ci et le
président doit montrer l'exemple du
comportement que l'on doit avoir pendant
une guerre les journalistes doivent
montrer l'exemple également et si
quelqu'un préfère partir en vacances
plutôt que de soutenir la guerre nous
devons montrer le contre-exemples et
faire comprendre que l'objectif est
commun que cette guerre c'est notre
cause commune qu'il s'agit là de dignité
humaine mais s'il vous plaît n'oubliez
pas que nous sommes tous des êtres
humains et
ce sont des êtres humains qui jusqu'ici
ont réussi à contrecarrer l'agression de
la Russie et nous sommes à un moment
important nous avons
supporté un coup d'arrêt à cette
agression mais maintenant nous devons
remporter la guerre nous ne pouvons pas
dire que l'on est en loi dans une dans
une situation de loi martiale et que on
ne peut pas se concentrer sur autre
chose non nous devons travailler nous
devons fournir des informations nous
devons frapper à toutes les portes faire
ce travail ensemble
il ne s'agit pas simplement du des
militaires de la politique d'information
de ce qui doit être fait au niveau du
gouvernement
ce sont certainement les piliers de
cette réforme et nous sommes dans un
état démocratique et nous devons
comprendre que
tout un chacun est appelé à défendre la
démocratie alors nous ne pouvons pas
forcer les gens à prendre les armes nous
ne sommes pas la Russie c'est ça le
paradoxe nous luttons pour devenir
membre de l'Union européenne nous sommes
une démocratie mais même en nous battant
nous devons nous battre avec dignité
ses valeurs merci
alors
j'ai deux questions si vous ne permettez
sur le processus d'intégration de
l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne tout
d'abord selon madame la Présidente
vanderleen vous progressez bien
l'Ukraine progresse bien mais vous
acceptez que l'Ukraine devra peut-être
attendre des années avant de devenir
membre à part entière de l'Union
européenne et que en Europe il y a
différents niveaux de soutien vis-à-vis
de l'Ukraine deuxièmement quel type
d'Union Européenne souhaitez-vous voir à
laquelle à quelle Union européenne
voulez-vous appartenir une Union
européenne ou chacun participe sur pied
d'égalité ou une Union européenne ou
certaines nations sont clairement aux
commandes
est-ce que toutes ces questions
s'adressent à moi
est-ce que toutes les questions vous me
les poser à moi
je pense avoir entendu j'espère que je
voulais entendre mais je pense avoir
entendu
les recommandations de la commission
nous pourrons entamer un dialogue sur
notre avenir
au sein de l'Union européenne n'est-ce
pas
alors la question que vous vous posez je
la pose à tout le monde ici présent nous
avons besoin d'unités dans ce cas là et
bien sûr
cette année nous souhaitons
véritablement que ce soit cette année
cela nous motivera cela motivera aussi
notre armée puisque vous le savez ils
sont attaqués sans cesse par les Russes
et c'est pour cela que nous luttons et
nous avons besoin de cette motivation
alors bien sûr la souveraineté les
Ukrainiens nos maisons protégées nos
enfants et aussi l'adhésion
et c'est pour cela que nous souhaitons
que ce soit cette année et quand je dis
cette année Charles je veux bien dire
cette année
nous serons de notre mieux
reprendra un moment quelconque merci
infiniment monsieur le Président
bienvenue ici à Bruxelles j'aimerais
revenir peut-être sur la partie plus
pratique de ces réunions vous avez
mentionné des avions de combat mais
êtes-vous satisfait des livraisons
d'armes reçu à ce jour et
qu'attendez-vous après la réunion
d'aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est une
visite symbolique même fortement
symbolique ou attendez-vous des
promesses des promesses concrètes
d'avion ou autre de vos homologues
européens et puis pour les présidents de
deux institutions
pensez-vous que des étapes pourront être
franchis très rapidement et est-ce qu'il
y a une décision à prendre à l'échelon
européen très prochainement merci
merci infiniment de cette question
je ne peux tout simplement pas rentrer à
la maison sans résultat
de moi et pour moi il est vraiment très
important que tous les échanges que nous
allons avoir porte leurs fruits et c'est
peut-être un peu
impertinent de ma part de le dire mais
ça n'est certainement pas cynique c'est
quelque chose
de très pragmatique il n'y a pas
d'émotion là-dedans les émotions elles
m'ont quitté le 24 février dernier nous
cherchons à survivre et poursuivre nous
avons besoin d'armes nous avons besoin
de ces armes là voilà pour survivre nous
avons besoin de cette aide financière et
je n'essaye pas à moi de me cacher
derrière les mots quand je dis ne
défendons nos valeurs communes je suis
absolument convaincue de ce que je dis
et j'espère que vous comprenez bien que
quand vous des l'Ukraine vous vous aider
vous-même et qu'il faut le faire de
telle façon que par la suite
les choses
ne soyez pas obligé de vous défendre
vous-même et donc essayer de nous
fournir dès que possible c'est cela que
je dis et puis il est évident que nous
avons entendu des messages positifs par
rapport à ces armes nous avons entendu
nos partenaires et maintenant ce que je
dis c'est qu'il faut concrètement aussi
faire entendre une voix qui soit
entendue jusqu'à la Russie
les pays de l'Union européenne ont fait
beaucoup cette année et ont une approche
voulu faire ma or nous avons besoin de
cette voie forte et de ce soutien
concret de l'Union européenne dans les
heures qui ont suivi cette agression
généralisée du 23 et du 24 février dans
les heures qui ont suivi l'Union
européenne a pris une décision
historique pour l'Union européenne c'est
la délivrance pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'Union d'armes à
l'Ukraine et j'oublierai pas nos appels
téléphoniques le vendredi le samedi
matin qui ont suivi ce conseil européen
et cette attaque par la Russie et le
moment où en quelques heures les 27
chefs d'État de gouvernement ont donné
leur mandat au ministres de la Défense
pour délirer des armes et nous savons
que dans les heures qui ont suivi les
premières armes arrivaient pour soutenir
les forces armées
ukrainiennes et donc lorsque il y a
quelques temps nous avons discuté avec
la proposition de venir ici à Bruxelles
rencontrer en personne les dirigeants
européens c'était pas simplement pour
offrir la possibilité d'une tribune
médiatique supplémentaire c'est bien
pour des décisions donc nous allons bien
ce qui fait la différence ce ne sont pas
les mots les mots sont importants bien
entendu mais ce n'est pas suffisant qui
fait la différence sont les capacités
militaires pour faire face pour
repousser cette agression et c'est bien
de cela dont il s'agit et je suis très
confiant je le répète encore une fois
que plus doit être fait et que plus sera
fait en terme de soutien et certainement
en terme de soutien militaire
Charles
très bien décrit la situation la
livraison des armes n'est pas décidée
par les institutions européennes c'est
une décision souveraine des États
membres de l'Union il est évident qu'ils
viennent coordination très forte et nous
avons vu d'ailleurs
sur le terrain les livraisons effectuées
par le reste
ailleurs nous avons effectivement une
coordination et je l'ai dit nous devons
faire plus et nous ferons plus nous
ferons plus sur l'économie sur
l'intégration de l'économie ukrainienne
dans l'économie européenne sur l'énergie
sur les corridors de solidarité sur le
soutien aux citoyen Ukrainiens qui
fuient les bombes de Poutine et on
trouvait refuge dans l'Union voilà
autant de choses que nous avons fait en
ce compris les sanctions également
européens là nous avons beaucoup
œuvré mais la livraison cette fois-ci
d'équipements militaires ça c'est une
décision souveraine des États membres
merci infiniment au Président zellenski
Monsieur Zelinski monsieur le Président
je vous souhaite un bon retour